you're so beautiful  they're beautiful who you choose girl  choose your whole life my daughter has  turned into a fine girl and a good man  has asked for her hand he never laid  eyes on something so pure  we're enough I gotta make your knees  hands what's wrong ago we has only thing  that makes any sense in this place when  the devil creeps in  you need someone to see the truth even  when you don't you got a choice you got  to make I couldn't find my way to the  truth of it  ain't listen to the spirits the circuit  will purify you a circuit will cleanse  you won't come on in your claim  [Music]  sorry not work communication she can't  be a part of your number  you cook bird with this  they're loners  that's what I'll let you do to me  [Music]  [Music]  you